Una mujer que va en bicicleta siguiendo
un camino junto a unas vías del tren a una velocidad
de 6 km/h...
creo que este dato es importante...
Cada día, ella lega al cruce
al mismo tiempo que llega el tren...
ella llega a un cierto cruce al mismo el tiempo
que llega el tren...
y un día ella sale 50 minutos tarde
y es superada por el tren a 6 kilómetro del cruce.
La pregunta es,
¿en cuántos minutos llegará el tren al cruce?
Y bueno, pues vamos a intentar hacer un diagrama
o un dibujo para ver qué es lo que está
pasando
y entender un poco mejor el problema.
Así que hablemos de un día normal,
en un día normal
ella recorre este camina a lado
de las vías del tren que por cierto,
es muy parecido a lo que me pasa a mí, yo también
voy con mi propia bicicleta en un camino a
lado de unas vías del tren,
pero bueno, ella
va hasta su trabajo
a lado de unas vías del tren,
voy a suponer que aquí empieza su recorrido,
por lo tanto
aquí es el tiempo igual a 0,
aquí éste de aquí va a ser el cruce
y por aquí pasa el tren y sigue adelante y bueno,
lo que me dicen es que ella va a una velocidad
de 6 km/h.
Y entonces no me dan
ni la distancia que tengo aquí,
ni me dan en cuanto tiempo
hace este recorrido,
sin embargo, lo que voy a suponer
porque me importa el tiempo
y mi pregunta
es algo que tiene que ver con el tiempo,
voy a suponer que
este recorrido lo hace,
la mujer que va en bicicleta
en "a" horas,
es decir,
que todo este recorrido completo lo hace en "a" horas,
hay que tener cuidado con el tiempo,
es muy importante.
Este recorrido lo ha ce en "a" horas,
y bueno,
eso es lo que pasa en un día común,
pero un día,
ella se levanta y hace todas sus actividades
50 minutos tarde,
por lo tanto vamos
a hablar de otro día,
de este día especial.
En este día especial,
ella comienza con un
tiempo de 50 minutos retrasados,
¿y cuánto es 50 minutos
a comparación de una hora?
Pues 50 entre 60 es lo mismo que 5/6, es decir,
empieza en un tiempo de 5/6,
va a empezar 5/6 después
de lo que empieza normalmente
su recorrido,
así que este tiempo de inicio
va a ser 5/6 de hora...
5/6 de hora.
Bueno,
¿y qué otra cosa dice el problema?
Ella es superada por el tren a 6 km del cruce,
a 6 km del cruce
y nos preguntan,
¿en cuánto tiempo el tren llegará al cruce?
Así que voy a suponer que aquí
es en el momento en el que el tren
y ella se encuentran ese día especial,
que por cierto es a 6 km del cruce,
la distancia que hay de aquí a acá, son 6 km.
Si yo lo que quiero saber es en cuántos minutos
el tren va a llegar al cruce a partir de este punto,
en lo que me tengo que fijar es que
si el tren cruza en este punto,
justo en un tiempo de "a" horas,
si nosotros nos tomamos
la diferencia entre el tiempo "t" igual a "a"
y sabemos en qué tiempo se cruzan
este día especial,
entonces vamos a saber
en cuánto tiempo
va a recorrer el tren lo que falta,
así que vamos a ver
si podemos determinar
este tiempo.
Fíjate bien, lo primero que quiero que veas,
es que de aquí a acá hay 6 km
y ella va a una velocidad
siempre de 6 km/h,
por lo tanto,
todo esto ella lo va a recorrer en una hora,
como ella va a una velocidad promedio
de 6 km/h, esto lo va a recorrer en una hora,
muy bien.
Y entonces, si todo este trayecto
lo recorre en "a" horas,
pues bueno,
este otro pedacito,
este otro pedazo del trayecto
lo va a recorrer ella
en "a" menos 1 hora.
Si todo lo recorre en "a" horas, entonces
de aquí a acá, hay "a" menos 1 hora,
porque aquí le falta 1 hora para llegar al cruce
donde siempre se encontraba con el tren,
entonces déjame bajar la pantalla,
este tiempo es de "a" menos 1 horas.
Muy bien, ya con esta información, entonces
ahora quiero que te des cuenta,
cómo vamos en los tiempos.
Fíjate bien, ella empezó en este día especial
5/6 de hora más tarde,
entonces,
¿en qué tiempo estamos parados justo aquí?
Bueno, pues en este tiempo, estamos a 5/6
porque ella empezó 5/6 más tarde,
más el tiempo que ella ha viajado hasta este punto,
el tiempo que ella ha viajado hasta este punto,
habíamos quedado que era "a" menos 1 horas,
¿y qué crees?
Yo creo que ya tenemos el conocimiento suficiente
y todos los datos y la información para poder
resolver este problema,
porque fíjate bien,
en un día normal, el tren y la mujer se intersectan
un tiempo de "a" horas,
después de que la mujer empezó su recorrido,
"a" horas se intersectaron,
en un tiempo de 5/6 más "a" menos 1
porque nuestra protagonista,
se despertó 50 minutos más tarde,
entonces si yo me tomo la diferencia
entre el tiempo normal
en el que ellos dos se cruzan
y el tiempo actual
en el que se cruzaron,
voy a obtener
en cuanto tiempo le falta al tren
para llegar al cruce donde originalmente
se encuentran.
Y para esto me voy a tomar entonces esta diferencia,
"a" que es el tiempo de siempre menos 5/6
más "a" menos 1,
que es el tiempo en donde
ahora se encontraron en este día especial,
¿y cuánto me queda de esto?
Me queda "a" menos 5/6
menos "a" más 1
y perfecto, porque esta "a"
y esta "a" se van
y solamente me queda, 1 menos 5/6
y esto está dado en horas,
lo cual por cierto es 1/6,
1/6 de hora es lo que le falta al tren recorrer
para llegar al cruce donde siempre se encuentran,
pero 1/6 de hora es 10 minutos,
por lo tanto
ya tengo la respuesta, al tren le faltan
10 minutos para llegar al cruce.
Y perfecto, porque ya con esto podemos encontrar
hasta la velocidad del tren
que podría ser otra variante
de este mismo problema,
pero en fin,
otro problema bien.
Así que nos vemos en el siguiente video.